metropolitan police commissioner
cressida dick has apologized to the
family of nicole smallman and bieber
henry for failings into the way police
handled missing persons reports about
the sisters after advice following an
independent office for police conduct
investigations the sisters had been
celebrating a birthday last june when
they were attacked and stabbed to death
in wembley in north west london uh
cressida dick said in a statement my
thoughts and deepest sympathies are with
the family and friends of nicole and
bieber for their tragic losses the way
we responded to information that nicole
and bieber were missing that weekend was
below the standard we should have
achieved and compounded the distress
felt by their loved ones
while we know that very sadly nicole and
bieber had been murdered in the early
hours of saturday june the 6th 2020
before they were reported missing if we
had responded better we may have saved
their friends and family immeasurable
pain
she continues i'm very sorry that the
level of service we provided fell short
we have contacted the family to ask if
they will allow me or if they prefer
another senior officer to visit them at
a time that is right to apologize in
person
that's uh from the commissioner of the
metropolitan police